Hello I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at where
the at symbol came from and how it was decided
to use it in email.
Ubiquitous today, until its use in email addresses,
the @ symbol was never really all that popular,
with this very fact being one of the reasons
it was chosen to be used in electronic message
addresses in the first place.
So where did the @ symbol come from?
The earliest known example of @ is found in
the 1345 Bulgarian translation of the 12th
century Manasses Chronicle, which gives a
brief synopsis of the history of the world
up to the end of the 11th century.
In it, @ was used as the symbol for “amin”
(amen).
No (presently) known surviving instance of
@ occurred again for a little over two centuries.
Seemingly independently “invented,” yet
another early example, this time of a proto-@
(with just the outside swoosh, but lacking
a defined center a), was used on a 1448 Spanish
registry, Taula de Ariza, referencing a shipment
of wheat from Castile to Aragon.
The earliest example of a full @ used in such
a commercial setting was discovered in 2000
in a letter written by a Florentine merchant,
Francesco Lapi, on May 4, 1536.
In this letter, Lapi used @ to denote a unit
of measure – an amphora (clay jar) of wine,
which is equivalent to about 1/13th of a barrel.
According to professor Giorgio Stabile of
Sapienza University of Rome, the discoverer
of the letter in question, the flourish around
the a for amphora was just one of many examples
of such embellishment of script found in Florence
at the time.
From here, Dr. Stabile theorized it was Italian
merchants who popularized the symbol, with
it traveling along with traded goods invoices
and receipts throughout Europe.
However, whether it really was the Italians
who popularized the symbol isn’t clear.
For instance, also during the 16th century
the @ symbol in Spain had progressed beyond
the aforementioned 1448 proto-@ into the fully
developed one, being used as the shorthand
symbol for the unit of measure called an arroba,
then equivalent to about 25 pounds or 11.3
kg.
(The arroba is generally thought to have derived
from the Arabic ????? pronounced ar-rub, which
meant “a quarter.”)
Whatever the case, from here @ evolved to
mean in a commercial setting “at the price
of”- i.e. 26 bags of flour @ $1 (so a total
of $26 for the purchase).
The symbol was also occasionally used in other
contexts, such as used to signify the French
à at least as early as the 17th century.
It should be noted here that before the discovery
of the 1345 and 1536 instances, it was generally
thought (and many still posit, including the
Oxford English Dictionary) that medieval monks
were the ones that invented the symbol to
use in place of the Latin ad, which meant
at, toward, by and about.
Lacking in any hard documented evidence pre-dating
the preceding instances, the idea behind this
theory is that the simple expedient of combining
the two letters (essentially an a with the
older ? form of the letter d) into a single,
smaller mark would have saved time and materials
during a period in history where every copy
of every book had to be written out by hand.
Many other such shorthand symbols were created
for just this reason.
For instance, the ampersand (&) is shorthand
for the Latin “et,” meaning “and.”
Another such classic shorthand was using “X”
for “Christ.”
The “X” in this case is actually the Greek
letter “Chi,” which is short for the Greek,
meaning “Christ”.
Scholars began using this particular shorthand
about a millennium ago.
In any event, the @ symbol labored in relative
obscurity for several hundred years until
one fateful day in 1971.
In that year, engineer Ray Tomlinson was implementing
his own version of a little program called
SNDMSG.
SNDMSG ran on the TENEX operating system and
was, essentially, just one of many flavors
of single-computer email- in other words,
an electronic mail system only capable of
sending messages from one user to another
on the same computer.
While this might seem absurdly useless given
the way people often use computers today,
back then programs like this were incredibly
handy.
For instance, the AUTODIN system created in
the early 1960s had a facility for sending
messages between users and, at its peak, handled
nearly 30 million electronic messages per
month.
MIT’s Compatible Time-Sharing System (CTSS),
also created in the 1960s, had a similar system
that allowed its numerous users to login from
some terminal and, among other things, exchange
messages stored on this single machine.
Tomlinson thought it would be interesting
to improve SNDMSG such that it could not only
be used for sending messages to other users
who could login to the same machine, but also
be used to send messages from one computer
to another via the budding ARPANET.
Tomlinson stated he just thought this tweak
to SNDMSG “seemed like a neat idea.
There was no directive to ‘go forth and
invent email’.
The ARPANET was a solution looking for a problem.
A colleague (Jerry Burchfiel) suggested that
I not tell my boss what I had done because
email wasn’t in our statement of work.
That was really said in jest because we were,
after all, investigating ways in which to
use the ARPANET.”
While writing the code for this, Tomlinson
had to decide how to designate that a message
should be sent to another computer on the
network, rather than a local account.
He fatefully settled on @, a symbol that only
made it on the standard keyboard in the first
place because of its usage in commerce.
Why did he choose @ over some other symbol?
For starters Tomlinson stated, “I looked
at the keyboard, and I thought: ‘What can
I choose here that won’t be confused with
a username?’
If every person had an ‘@’ sign in their
name, it wouldn’t work too well.
But they didn’t.
They did use commas and slashes and brackets.”
That left just a few symbols to choose from
that weren’t being commonly used.
He noted that, at the time, “The purpose
of the at sign (in English) was to indicate
a unit price (for example, 10 items @ $1.95).”
So,
"it made sense.
[@] didn’t appear in names so there would
be no ambiguity about where the separation
between login name and host name occurred…
[@] also had no significance in any editors
that ran on TENEX.
I was later reminded that the Multics time-sharing
system used [@] as its line-erase character.
This caused a fair amount of grief in that
community of users…"
The resulting format was loginname@host (and
later loginname@host.domain once the DNS system
was developed).
And so it was that what is generally credited
as being the first true network email, at
least as we think of it, was sent in late
1971 by Tomlinson.
Of this momentous occasion, Tomlinson said,
“The first message was sent between two
[DEC-10] machines that were literally side
by side.
The only physical connection they had (aside
from the floor they sat on) was through the
ARPANET.
I sent a number of test messages to myself
from one machine to the other.
The test messages were entirely forgettable
and I have, therefore, forgotten them.
Most likely the first message was QWERTYUIOP
or something similar.
(Essentially quickly randomly typing gibberish
on the keyboard.)
When I was satisfied that the program seemed
to work, I sent a message to the rest of my
group explaining how to send messages over
the network.
The first use of network email announced its
own existence.”
And the rest, as they say, is history.